how's it going everybody
international master danny wrench here
continuing our series on the type of
tactics you need to know
the five fork themes fork patterns that
we have organized for you
are night forks pretty obviously
pawn forks
double attacks which are classified as
forks but by pieces other than the
knight in the pawn so double attack
forks
then we have something i like to call
tempo forks the recognition of a tempo
square you can move to to either execute
a fork after that
or one that immediately forks something
and then finally loose squares and
pieces forks recognition of weak squares
and loose pieces and how you might apply
a double attack to two at once or to use
them on your way to an attack so again
you can see the five types of fork
themes we'll be learning in this series
here knight forks pawn forks double
attack tempo forks and
loose pieces and squares forks let's
move on to the first position
of course the most common type of knife
fork you would
be aware of is is a fork where a knight
attacks either a king and a queen or a
queen and a rook these are the royal
forks the family forks because we are
forking the most powerful pieces on the
board
this one of course comes from the fried
liver opening
with e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 and after bishop c4
knight f6 we have the two knights with
knight tg5
d5 would be the more traditional fried
liver
but in this game
we're playing bishop to c5 just to
highlight exactly what a fork is
as we did in the first video where we
showed a very very basic version of a
fork you can use your imagination to put
the king on d6 or g5 or anywhere else
where you might just imagine what it
looks like when a knight is having one
of those rare opportunities to fork all
three of the most valuable pieces at
once
the fried liver is most easily stopped
for those of you wondering
by challenging the center with d5 which
closes the diagonal after which black
can play both knight a5 and knight to d4
as interesting and dynamic moves
our first position masters you have
15 seconds experts you have less than a
minute
1600 to 2000 you should have about a
minute only need about a minute 1200 to
1600 shouldn't need more than a few
minutes maybe let's say three minutes
for the clock
and um
below that you can have five minutes
this is a recognition of an opportunity
to create a fork we're continuing along
the theme of a night fork
assuming you have paused the video and
we are ready to know the answer here we
go black plays the move rook takes e5 of
course
removing the knight you would love to uh
just play this fork right away but
you'll be captured by the only piece
capable of competing with a knight's
forking ability another night
so we remove that knight
and at the same time apply an attraction
tactic if you will that brings the rook
onto the forkable square knight to f3
check followed by winning material
so in quick review we'll leave this
final position up as we bring up the
five bullet points here of what are the
types of forks we learned
night forks of course
pawn forks
we talked about double attack the
traditional attacking two things at once
with the queen or brooke or bishop
tempo forks this this sort of art of
using a using a threat gaining a tempo
so that then you can deliver a fork
especially when it's not possible for
that or in some cases using a temple
square to actually be giving a double
attack that might improve your position
as we saw with the queen coming to e5
and then finally just a recognition of
loose and vulnerable pieces and that's
really what tactics are all about
i know that some people might say well
isn't it all kind of the same theme
you're right i mean we're talking about
a fork and a fork essentially is a
double attack attacking two pieces of
one so every single theme we look at is
going to have ties to the other in the
sense that
why why do we even call a knight a fork
and a queen a double attack i don't know
it's really the same type of pattern the
ultimate goal is that we're either
winning material or improving our
position significantly by a double
attack as we've seen in all of them what
we're trying to do here is just give you
guys some themes uh to sort of
understand that if it's not obvious to
you where a fork is or what the best
opportunity is for a double attack maybe
this video and seeing how it was sort of
broken down that we can look to gain a
tempo maybe we just okay i don't see an
opportunity for a tactic have i
considered all the ways to take
advantage of the loose or vulnerable
pieces these are the thought processes
you would have on your approach and
hopefully
you'll remember what what the different
things are that you can look for when
executing a fork and a pin and as well
as a lot of the other videos to come
and
i love you all very very much and go
ahead and go get to work see you around
on chess.com everybody